これ一つ一つの丁寧にこのセットセットにして説明した方が因果法則の理解はすごく幅広くなりますけども
まあ時間の関係もありますしね
サンガーパッチャ ウパーダナ
この渇愛が生まれたならば
ウパーダナの固執 固く
何て言いますか 執着するというか
掴む ものが囚われる 固執というんですけど
固く物事にとらわれる
もう囚われているんですね
六処が生まれた瞬間でもう感覚が生まれてきて
感覚によって渇愛が生まれてきて
渇愛が生まれた頃でもう外の世界に囚われて
もう動かない状態で動けない状態になってしまっちゃうんです
それから本当はこのウパーダナはもう何でか何であるかというすごい説明あります
そこら辺で思い出せばいいと思いますけどね
一応までで終わらないと
話出す ウパーダナパッチャ・バハ
で ウパーダナというのは固執
固執が生まれるとバハが生まれるんだと
バハっていうのはバハ
有と書いているんですね
漢字では それだけでちょっとわからないんですから
それだけのポイントをちょっと説明します
で ウパーダナというのはもう囚われているんですね
何に囚われているかと
眼耳鼻舌身の対象に囚われているんですね
色見 何とか何て言いますか
色 色声香味触法に囚われているんですね
もう離れなくなっちゃうんです
で 離れなくなったら その人がその世界にずっとしがみついて
いろんな活動 行動しなくちゃいけない
離れ 何か見て それから離れられなくなったら
その人はそれをずっと見ているんですね
行動を起こすんです 離れない
囚われているんだ だから行動をやめたということにならないんですね
離れなくなったということは
かなり忙しくなったということなんですね
だからこの囚われたということは
人を捕まって 両手も両足も板に鎖でつけておいたような感じではないんです
口も閉めておけば喋ることもできないし
目隠ししちゃったら見ることもできないし
その人だったらもう手も足も何も動かせないのでじーっとしているしかないんですね
そういう囚われではないんですね
それだったら行動停止だからね
ありがたいんだけど で
この固執っていうのは面白いものいっぱいあるんですね
聞きたい音はいっぱいあるし
見たいものはいっぱいあるし
味わいたい味はいっぱいあるし
体に触ってほしいものはいっぱいあるし
考えたいものはいっぱいあるし
だから行動を起こしちゃうんですね
もう生きているんですね
その人は だから生きるということはそういうことなんです
忙しくなって 見るは聞くは味わうは
それは生きるということなんですね
だからバハというんですね
生きているということはそんなものだからね
見る 聞く 味わう 嗅ぐとかね
考えると だから結局見る
聞く 味わう 考える このこと自体に有とバハというし
それで何か発見できませんか？一番前の項目でサンカーラと
行と言ったら何ですかね
あれも同じことなんですね
行動なんですね だから囚われた人がまた行動を起こしてるんですね
見たいものは見る 聞きたいものは聞くということで
見たくないものは見えないようにする
聞きたくないものから離れようとすると
そのように行動 起こしているんです
いわゆるサンカーラなんです
ですから 伝統的な仏陀法ではサンカーラ
行イコール有なんです
だから 括弧の中で書かなくちゃイコールサンカーラなんですね
じゃあサンカーラだったらなんで正直にサンカーラと言わないかと
やっぱり因果のこの因果法則のこれシークエンシャルな説明だから
ちょっと危ないところはあります
物事をシークエンシャルで
いわゆる順番で説明できるわけじゃないんですね
やっぱりそれでもちょっとそれしか人間は理解できませんから
ほんのちょっと順番で説明してみようとやっているところですから
ぴったしというのもなくなっちゃうとこもあります
それからアヴィッチャーから無明から行が生じると
固執から行が生じると言っちゃうと
おかしいんじゃないんですか？原因と結果の関係で見れば
どっちですかと聞きたくなるでしょうね
無明から行が生じる 固執から行が生じる
じゃあ行の原因は何ですかね
それだったら だからやっぱり因果の方程式に合わないんですね
ですから 行という漢字は使えないんです
行を だからって同義語を使って逃げるんですかと
それだったら 同義語を使って逃げるわけにも
同義語でも同じですからね
だから働きイコールですけど
ババそのものはサンカーラではないんです
ババと言ったらこの人は生きてることだから
普通の生きてる世界にまた帰って意味するんですね
だから生きてる世界 生きてる世界で何ですかと言えば
行動することであって
行動することなんですかというか
業をすることであってというふうな
ちょっと長い話になっちゃうんです
ですから 捕らわれた人は生きてるんだという考え方で言ってるんですね
だからババは存在ですから
生きてることだから これ捕らわれてるんだからなんですね
それでお釈迦様の立場から見れば
あなた捕らわれなかったならば
この眼耳鼻舌身に それだけのことや
それでババがなくなっちゃうんだと
眼耳鼻舌身に捕らわれなかったならば
ババ存在がなくなっちゃうでしょうと
だからそこは解脱ですよと
だからこの一項目の中で全部入ってるんです
だからこういうのは決して中途半端な言葉じゃないんで
ものすごい厳密な因と果
果なんです だからどこからでも説明できそうと
無明からでも説明できるんだと
で 固執から有が生まれるんだと
固執から存在が生まれるんだと
固執は分かっていることで
あれも欲しい これも欲しいと
やっぱり見て 見たいものを聞きたいもの
味わいたいものはいっぱい
あってもう離れなくなって囚われていると
だからあなたは生きているんだと
もう終わりがないんだと
あなたの人生は キリがなく
次から次へとやっているんだから
何かやったんだからといって苦しみが消えるんだったらいいんだけど
それ消えませんね もっとやりたくなるんだから終わりがないと
だから固執さえなくなっちゃったら存在がなくなっちゃうんだと
存在がなくなるということは解脱ですからね
そこでサンカーラっていうのは行為であって業だから
次にババパッチャージャーティ
そこでまた来世になっちゃうんです
で ここでサンカーラ 業が溜まるでしょうに
行動しているんだから
行動すると当然ヴィンヤーナが生まれるんですね
だからここでサンカーラ
業 有というのはね で 行動ですから
業だから働きやってるんだから新しくヴィンヤーナが生まれるはずなんですね
ですから この行動によって
この行動に 場によってよって
ジャーティ 生まれがまた現れる
で この場合は来世なんですね
だからここへジャーティっていうのは生なんですけど
その生は来世になっちゃうんですね
だから必ずしも来世でなくてもいいんです
だからこれすごい複雑なんです
ある ある角度で来世になるんであって
違う角度で見るとまた違うことなんですね
例えば人間が行動すると
まあ現代的な説明になっちゃうと
で 行動する 生きているということによって
いろんなことを生まれてくるでしょうに
生きてるんだから 家を建てなくちゃいけない
結婚しなくちゃいけない
子供作らなくちゃいけない
仕事をしなくちゃいけないとかね
病気になったら病気を治さなくちゃいけないとか
ありとあらゆる現象が生まれてくるんです
だからジャーティというのは生まれだけなんです
なぜ新しい現象が生まれてくるかというと
その人の存在 生きてるっていう気持ちがあるんだからなんです
なんで生きてるという気持ちがあるかというと
やっぱり囚われてるだからなんです
ですから これ必ずしも来世の新しい生まれでなくても意味は生じます
だから我々はどんな角度で因果法則を見るかって角度はたくさんあります
とにかく新しい生まれが現れますね
また生まれたらもう簡単に言いますね
ジャータパッチャ 生まれた人には何があるかというと
ジャラーマラナ そのテキストを見てください
ジャラーマラナン ソーカパリデバドゥッカドゥーマナッスパーヤサーサンバヴァンティ
で生まれたならばジャラー老いること
マラナン死ぬこと 生まれた人には老いることも死ぬこともありますからね
それだけじゃない 苦し
憂い 悲しみ 苦しみ 全て現れちゃいますと
で それは来世で じゃあ今世でないかと
今世で生まれてるんだからあるんですね
じゃあ過去世で 過去世で生まれていたんだから同じくあるんですからね
で そういう風にこの過去世も同じで
今世もまるっきり同じで
来世もまるっきり同じだから輪廻なんです
例えば A から B が生まれるという
B から C が生まれるんだと
C から A が生まれると言っちゃったらどうなります？どうなってですか
で  A があって  A から B が生まれるとする
B からは C が生まれるとする
C からは A が生まれるとすると
どうなるんですかね 終わりがないでしょ
同じ一点で回転してるわけじゃないんです
例えば A があって  A は B を作ったでしょうに
B は C を作ってしまうでしょうに
C が A を作ってしまっちゃう
その2番目の絵は新しいんですけどね
前の絵と違いますからね
あの あのシーケンシャルで時間で考えればね
例えばこれは3日に分けてみると 1
日目はAが生まれて 2
日目はBが生まれるんだとAから
それで3日目はBからCが生まれるでしょうに
そうすると4日目はCからAが生まれるでしょうに
ですから同じじゃないんですね
同じじゃないんだけど
グルグルグルグルグルグルグル回っちゃうんです
終わりがないんですね
そういう考え方で この十二因縁がこの ABC の段階に分けてるんです
同じではないんです 言葉だけ同じ
だからこの輪廻っていう概念が生まれたそうです
というわけで 仏教の輪廻っていうのは
単なるインド人が人が死んだら生まれ変わりますよということは
まあ何のことなく受け入れたっていうのは
まあ全く違う話なんです
何のことなく受け入れたんじゃないんです
たまたま似ている言葉使ってるだけで
仏教の輪廻っていうのはまるっきり普通の宗教で言ってる輪廻とは違うんです
だからこのサイクルを見ても A
という人がいて Bという人が生まれるでしょうに A
が死んだらBが生まれるし B
が死んでCが生まれるんだけど C
が死んだらまたAが生まれるんだけど
前のAと今のAはまるっきり同一人物だと言えますかね
そこは言えませんし 違いますね
だから違うんだけど 全く無関係かというと無関係でもないんですね
過去にいた私は今いる私とまるっきり違う人物なんですけど
無関係でもない もし私が過去生で犬でしたならば
犬と私は何の似ているところなんもないし
でも無関係でもないんですね
そういうことでアヴィッチャーとサンカーラ
無明と業が過去生で 業から識が生まれるというところから今世で
今世で識が生まれて それから名色が出てきて
名色から六処が出てきて
六処から六根が出てきて
六根から触が感覚が生まれてきて
感覚からから渇愛が生まれてきて
渇愛からは故終がもう
もう束縛が出てきて 束縛からまだまた生きてるという行動が出てきて
そこでまた業が積み重なったままちゃうんです
そこで業によって新しくまた生まれると
で だから本当の因果説っていうのは
こういうのリストに書けないはずなんです
どうしても言葉では書けないんです
書けない やっぱり余分な言葉は全部取って
繰り返し文句は全部取って十二を選んでる
十二選んだのはお釈迦様ですから
別にアビダンマでやったわけじゃないんです
で どういうわけかというと
例えば「バワパッチャージャーティ」
存在から生まれが いわゆる行動から生まれが新しく生まれるんだというでしょうし
で なんで人は行動するんですかね
無明だからでしょうに
だからずっと無明があるんです
そこで無明っていうのは心の状態でしょうに
だからずっとヴィンニャーナがあるんです
だからどうしてもこれは言葉では語れないんです
無明から行が生じる 行から識が生じるという場合も
行と無明があって識が生じるんですね
そこで識からヴィンニャーナからナーマルーパ
名色でしょうに それでもう無明も行も識もあって
名色が生まるってことになっちゃう
ということは一瞬でも何か欠けてるわけじゃなくて
全部十二のセットで我々はいるんです
それで十二のセットとは言いにくいんだけど
一応セットとしていつでも全部あるんです
じゃあこの辺で終わりましょう